ahora que sabemos un poco más sobre
configuración electrónica comenzaremos a
ver lo que son los electrones de
valencia que son los electrones que
están asociados a un átomo y son los que
tienen más probabilidad de reaccionar
con otros átomos o formar uniones ser
perdidos separarse del átomo o ser
compartidos de alguna manera con otros
átomos hablamos un poquito sobre ellos
cuando estuvimos analizando la tabla
periódica pero ahora vamos a hablar al
respecto un poquito más formal y vamos a
usar las estructuras de punto de louis
para poder visualizarlos como les
comenté estos electrones de valencia
tienden a ser los que tienen mayor
energía o los que están más alejados y
ustedes me pueden decir bueno que no son
los electrones los de mayor energía los
que siempre están más alejados bueno es
cierto cuando hablamos del bloque s que
es el que está aquí en que estoy
resaltando de este lado
o cuando hablamos del bloque p que es
este otro bloque de este otro lado
pero esto no necesariamente se cumple
para los metales de transición es por
eso que no estoy afirmando este
enunciado que se cumple para todos sólo
tiende a hacer que los electrones de
mayor energía son los que están más
alejados pero no siempre se cumple así
que analicemos esto un poco y vamos a
dibujar unas estructuras de punto de
louis comencemos con el más simple de
los elementos el hidrógeno el hidrógeno
tiene solo un electrón su configuración
electrónica es 1 s 1 así que su único
electrón también es electrón de valencia
es el electrón que usará el hidrógeno
para reaccionar se le puede quitar al
hidrógeno y en ese momento se vuelve
unión positivo o puede compartir este
electrón con otro átomo por lo que a lo
mejor ese hidrógeno podría pretender que
tiene una configuración más estable como
el helio pero sólo tiene un electrón y
es el electrón de valencia que estoy
mostrando aquí lo señalamos como un
punto arriba del hidrógeno ahora que hay
de los otros elementos de este grupo no
sé digamos el sodio cuál es la
configuración electrónica del sodio
bueno para abreviar voy a decir que
tiene
en la configuración del neón el neón
tiene 1 s 22 s 226 y es lo que esto
representa y para llegar al sodio
tendremos 3s unos cuantos electrones de
valencia hay aquí bueno el electrón que
tiene más energía y que está más alejado
del núcleo o quizás debería decir que es
el electrón que se encuentra o quizá
debo decir que es el electrón quien no
se encuentra en una capa estable una
capa que no ha llegado a su estado de
estabilidad completa y aquí sólo hay un
electrón el electrón 3s 1 así que sodio
también podemos representarlo así sólo
tiene un electrón de valencia ese es el
electrón que puede quitarse de este
átomo aunque quizá pueda verse
involucrado en un enlace covalente
veamos los electrones de valencia de
otros elementos diferentes al hidrógeno
y al sodio pero aquí lo importante que
tenemos que darnos cuenta y por eso
elegí estos ejemplos del hidrógeno y del
sodio es que todos estos elementos del
grupo 1 van a tener un electrón de
valencia un electrón que es el que
pueden perder y formarán unión o que
pueden usar para formar un enlace
covalente ahora veamos al helio él
es un elemento bastante interesante ya
que todos los demás gases nobles tienen
8 electrones de valencia lo que los hace
bastante estables pero el helio solo
tiene 2 electrones de valencia pero la
razón por la que se incluye de este lado
es porque el helio es bastante estable
ya que para esta primera capa sólo se
necesitan 2 electrones para estar llenos
para llegar a un estado de estabilidad
así que el helio tiene dos su
configuración electrónica es 1 s 2 y de
nuevo la razón por la que está aquí con
los gases nobles es porque es bastante
estable y se comporta de manera similar
a estos gases nobles y es por eso que
ahora usamos el helio para llenar los
globos aerostáticos en lugar del
hidrógeno ya que es más difícil que
exploten como lo hizo el hindenburg pero
ya que vemos que sólo tiene 2 electrones
de valencia pues deberíamos incluirlo en
el grupo 2 ya que todos los elementos de
este grupo 2 tienen dos electrones de
valencia así que en este sentido pasa es
un argumento bastante válido y ya lo
hemos visto tenemos un buen argumento
para poner el helio en este lado pues
todos los elementos del grupo 2 van a
tener dos electrones de valencia ahora
pasemos a uno de los elementos más
interesantes y verza
en la tabla periódica el elemento que
sienta las bases de la vida como la
conocemos y ese es el carbono los invito
a que pausa en el vídeo y piensen sobre
lo que acabamos de hablar piensen
cuántos electrones de valencia tiene el
carbono y cómo será su estructura de
puntos de luis bueno la configuración
electrónica del carbono va a ser la
misma que el helio más vamos a tener 12
c 2 y 2 p 2 cuántos elecciones va a
tener en su capa más externa pues tendrá
estos 4 2 más 2 así que podemos verlos
como 1 2 3 4 puntos alrededor de este
símbolo 4 electrones de valencia y
porque esto es interesante bueno ahora
podemos considerar si ya hemos visto la
estructura de los electrones de valencia
del carbono y del hidrógeno ya podremos
predecir qué tipo de moléculas se pueden
formar con ellos por ejemplo al carbono
le gustaría pretender que tiene 8
electrones y así se sentiría más estable
como un gas noble como el neón y al
hidrógeno le gustaría tener otro
electrón 12
para completar su capa más externa de
manera que se sienta más estable como el
helio si esto es un átomo de carbono y
estos son átomos de hidrógeno aquí están
en diferente color un hidrógeno u otro
hidrógeno otro hidrógeno y otro
hidrógeno más así que tenemos estos
enlaces que podrían formarse entre el
carbono y el hidrógeno solamente con lo
que aprendimos acerca de los electrones
de valencia de ambos elementos así que
usando estas estructuras de louis yo
puedo predecir qué tipo de moléculas se
pueden formar puedo imaginar que tengo
que el carbono comparte sus 4 electrones
de valencia con cuatro átomos diferentes
de hidrógeno así que comparten estos
electrones con cada uno de los
hidrógenos de manera que el carbono
puede sentir que tiene 8 electrones de
valencia y cada uno de los hidrógenos
puede sentir que tiene 2 electrones de
valencia si hiciéramos esto y dijéramos
bueno pues puede existir una molécula de
este tipo en la naturaleza y que luce
bastante estable de hecho tendrían razón
esta es la molécula de metano y la forma
en la que se muestra con una estructura
de louis y ahora
de representar esto con una estructura
de puntos de louis esto que acabo de
hacer es algo no tan convencional
normalmente estos pares de electrones se
representa como un enlace covalente este
se representa como un enlace covalente
este es otro enlace covalente aquí hay
otro enlace covalente y finalmente este
último enlace covalente cada uno de
estos enlaces son dos electrones de
valencia que están siendo compartidos
mutuamente así que el carbono siente que
puede tener 2 468 electrones que están
siendo compartidos y cada uno de los
hidrógenos siente que tiene 2 electrones
lo que los lleva a un estado más estable
y cualquiera de los elementos que se
encuentran en el grupo del carbono todos
van a tener 4 electrones de valencia por
ejemplo el estaño el estaño en neutro va
a tener aún cuando el estaño tiene 15
electrones aquellos que van a reaccionar
serán los cuatro que se encuentran en su
capa más externa 1 2
4 así que ustedes pueden predecir que
quizá pueda formar enlaces no tan
diferentes como lo hace el carbono y
puede reaccionar de manera similar a
este o que ya también de manera similar
al silicio incluso hay personas que
piensan que podría existir vida en otros
planetas basadas en silicio en lugar de
carbono ya que el silicio tendrán tipos
de enlaces similares al carbono y podrá
formar estructuras parecidas por esta
misma razón y bueno aquí mencionamos que
tenemos estos metales de transición el
bloque de de aquí y esos otros dos
bloques realmente van acá estos son
casos especiales ya que nosotros
aprendimos que una vez que nos
encontramos en el cuarto periodo por
ejemplo si quisiéramos hacer la
configuración electrónica del hierro
para esta configuración electrónica del
hierro podremos tomar como base la
configuración electrónica del argón y
luego vamos a 4s dos y ahora que estamos
en el bloque de no vamos a llenar la sub
capa 4 d
tenemos que regresar y llenar la capa
anterior tenemos que regresar a llenar
el psuv orbital 3d con 1 2 3 4 5 6
así que es tres de seis y aquí es donde
se vuelve la cosa un poco más ambigua
cuáles son los electrones de mayor
energía puede no ser que se encuentran
en el sub orbital de cuáles son los más
lejanos por los que se encuentran en la
sub capa 4 los 4 s 2 y por es que la
forma de reaccionar del hierro es
bastante especial al menos basándonos en
la configuración electrónica superficial
que tiene es un poco más difícil de
predecir
se sabe que el hierro pierde un electrón
puede perder dos electrones puede perder
tres electrones así que se puede tener
un cierta combinación de estos
electrones de alta energía junto con los
que están más alejados una combinación
de estos electrones de alta energía con
los que se encuentran más alejados
entonces el hierro así como todos los
demás metales de transición así que el
hierro como todos los demás elementos de
transición el encontrar sus selecciones
de valencia se vuelva un poquito más
difícil de predecir algunas personas o
incluso algunos libros de texto dicen
que todos los elementos de transición
tienen dos electrones de valencia ya que
llegan al 4 s 2 y después se regresan a
llenar una sub capa anterior así que
dicen bueno esto
los electrones de valencia para todos
estos metales de transición pero esto no
se cumple para todos ellos ya que
tenemos casos especiales como el cobre y
el cromo que tienen un 4 s 1 y empiezan
a llenar el 3 d dependiendo de las
circunstancias a veces lo hacen de otra
manera pero incluso para los otros
elementos de transición como el hierro
esto no son los únicos no es
necesariamente el caso de que estos sean
los dos únicos electrones que puedan
compartirse o que puedan perderse puede
pasar también con los electrones de las
suv capaces que tienen más energía y
también podrían verse involucrados en
reacciones